mmm well thank you very much for the
kind introduction drill and to dawn and
to see for an OB I for putting together
this incredible workshop I think on
behalf of all of the scientist we've had
some very stimulating discussions in the
first day and a half and they'll
continue into tomorrow but thank you
very much to all of the support for
bringing us here in getting us to talk
about this very fascinating topic so i
tried to put together a public seminar
based on 50 years of information based
on information that came out of the the
last two days of discussion and some
predictions of what might come tomorrow
and bring it all into a kind of package
to deliver to you today and what i would
like you to take our two primary
messages from my presentation this
evening the first is that there is
enormous variation in the clinical
presentation in autism there is no such
thing as classic autism autism is in
fact a collection of rare disorders or
conditions that share our clinical
features second there is enormous
variation the genetic factors involved
in autism with dozens of jeans now
identified to be involved as I would
discuss understanding the jeans and the
factors that influence them promised to
lead to personalize treatment in autism
this beautiful painting from Tom
Thompson perhaps Canada's most famous
artist offers a good illustration of how
just like the trees in the forest and
autumn each individual with autism is
unique both on the outside and the
inside on the next three slides I
selected six captions from over 50 years
of scientific literature on the topic of
autism that in fact in my opinion
capture the essence of the complexity of
understanding the Enigma of autism
so first the first quote it all depends
on the way you see things said the woman
on the other side of the little table in
my office what can seem like a
disability one day can be a talent or a
gift on another the second quote what is
so tragic is that the impairments and
social interaction in communication and
in play at play at the strike at the
very heart of what it means to be a
child these are quotes from a book that
my colleague dr. Peters Amari from
McMaster University used in his book
called understanding children with
autism and Asperger's syndrome I don't
think Peter is here tonight
unfortunately but he is part of the
workshop this week the third quote an
enigma in asd is the 421 male the female
gender bias which may rise to 11 to one
when considering Asperger's syndrome to
be involved this is from a scientific
paper than I'll touch on what a bit
later coming from our group a few years
ago next children with a distant degrade
of disorder show completely normal
development until age 4 then regress and
develop autistic behaviors just like
those in autism and this is a quote from
my colleague developmental pediatrician
one year Roberts in the Toronto Star
just a few months ago next people with
autism see the forest for the tree but
they see the trees in exquisite detail
and that's from utta Fred who's a
long-standing clinical scientist who
studies the phenomena of autism and next
examination of monozygotic twin pairs
concordant for autism show enormous
clinical heterogeneity even when pairs
shared exactly the same segregating
alleles and what that means is they
share what we expect to be the same
genes and this is from Sir Michael
Rutter who's in the audience today who
really has written the book in the
history of autism and I think we stand
on his shoulders and others in this
audience when we discussed the great
advances over the last 50 years so what
is autism
this is how I see autism as a scientist
I'd like to use Venn diagrams with
overlapping circles but many people
think of the child or the individual
with autism as someone who is mute
completely self-absorbed and who sits in
a corner in rocks all day other common
misperceptions are that people with
autism are violent and aggressive and
while this can be true there is in fact
enormous very variety and how autism
presents an individual's while it's true
that many people with autism are not
capable of functionally useful language
a substantial proportion perhaps more
than fifty percent are able to use
language at least to have their
essential needs met it is also true that
the vast majority of children with
autism do interact socially with adults
but do so in a limited unusual and fixed
fashion there is also enormous variation
in their cognitive abilities some
children with autism are able to perform
only rudimentary operations and some
will never learn to read others however
are able to perform the most astonishing
mathematical calculations or have
encyclopedia knowledge of specific
topics or as Glenn Gould then the person
named after this theatre could play Bach
better than it's it's own composer in
spite of the enormous diversity there
are three features that characterize all
individuals with autism spectrum
disorder they are in parents impairments
and social and reciprocal social
interaction impairments in verbal and
nonverbal communication and a preference
for repetitive solitary and stereotyped
interests or activities these general
three general characteristics make up
the autistic triad it is also important
to point out that the symptoms and
behaviors vary with a developmental
level and age of the individual it can
have and can change dramatically over
time but importantly these changes are
usually a variation on the theme already
contained in the notion of the autistic
try on this year the single term autism
spectrum disorder or disorders or ASD
has come to encompass the previous
categories of Asperger's disorder
autistic disorder childhood
disintegrative disorder
and pervasive development disorder not
otherwise specified so i will use autism
and asd kind of interchangeably in my
presentation in addition to the autism
tried of symptoms individuals with
autism can exhibit many mental health or
general health conditions most often
observed are challenges like attention
deficit disorder or attention deficit in
fourteen percent of cases sleep disorder
in fifteen percent of cases learning
disability in twenty-two percent of
cases depression twenty-eight percent
anxiety and up to forty five percent
digestive system disorders and up to
forty seven percent and brain or spinal
conditions notably epilepsy in fifty one
percent of cases so it is important to
point out that in some cases these
conditions may occur with co-occur with
autism but it is also possible that they
could be a result of the autism for
example sleep disorders or perhaps even
cause the autism itself for example
local brain damage caused by epileptic
seizures perhaps may induce the autism
per se and this adds yet another layer
of complexity when studying the complex
enigma that we call autism and this data
was taken from a recently released study
in Ontario and just in 2013 that had
done a very comprehensive survey of
these statistics in the Ontario
population now even more complex are the
neuropsychological theories contemplated
to explain autism which are summarized
on this slide and I am no expert at this
at all here but let's try to get through
two major categories of cognitive
theories have been proposed about the
links between autistic brains and
behavior the first category focuses on
deficits and social cognition the
empathizing system systemizing theory
postulates that autistic individuals can
systemize that is they can develop
internal rules of operation to handle
events inside the brain but are less
effective at empathizing by handling
events generated by other agents an
extension of this the extreme male brain
theory hypothesizes that the autism that
autism is index
dream case of the male brain from the
evolutionary perspective this model is
based on the idea that males were the
hunter-gatherers requiring skills of
intense focus to the contrary the
females who stayed at home acquired
genetic traits that favored social
interaction and the ability for
multitasking these theories are somewhat
related to the earlier theory of mind
approach which hypothesizes that
autistic behavior arises from an
inability to ascribe mental states to
oneself and others however most studies
have found no evidence for impairment in
autistic individuals ability to
understand other people's basic
intentions or goals instead data
suggests that impairments are found in
understanding more complex social
emotions or in considering others points
of views the second category focuses on
non social or general processing of the
so-called executive functions such as
working memory planning and inhibition a
strength of this theory is predicting
stereotyped behavior in the narrow
interests observed in autism part of
this week central coherence theory
hypothesizes that a limited ability to
see the big picture where the forest
underlies the central disturbance in
autism one strength of this theory is
predicting special talents and peaks and
performance in autistic people a related
theory enhanced perceptual functioning
focuses more on the superiority of
locally oriented and perceptual
operations in autistic individuals in my
opinion and as was pointed out I'm a
geneticist not a neuropsychologist both
theories are in part correct but maybe
not complete social cognition theories
poorly address autism's rigid and
repetitive behaviors while the non
social theories have difficulty
explaining social impairment and
communication difficulties how all of
these theories tied together in with the
genetics and imaging studies that I
would present later needs to be a major
area of research in the years to come as
I will allude to at the end of my
presentation a big challenge in the
field will be to marry
neuropsychological and evolutionary
theory if we were to fully understand
the complexities of autism so if I
haven't
used to enough or at least convinced you
of the challenges of understanding
autism which is probably the most
complex problem that I think one could
tackle this next slide summarizes the
complex systems that will need to begin
to explore in our pursuit to crack the
Enigma of autism these include the the
genome the human genome the brain and
the human being itself the genome is the
complete set of instructions the DNA
characteristics that you inherit from
each year parents and this instruction
book or blueprint of your life is
encoded by six billion chemical letters
of DNA information you inherit three
billion roughly from your mom and three
billion from your dad encoded by these
DNA structure instructions are 30,000
sets of genes strung along to 23 pairs
of chromosomes and of course each of
these genes is subjected to millions of
years of evolution adding intricate
complexities in an experimental process
that has built us to what we are today
next we have the brain which is
comprised of over 100 billion neurons
these are the brain cells that are
comprised of what we call dendrites and
dendritic spines and arms and I'll come
back to this a little bit later these
are the the branches or twigs if you
will that communicate with each other at
the synapse of the cell and if you take
these hundred billion neurons there's
over 100 trillion neuronal connections
that occur at the synapse so this is the
complexity in the human brain it's
almost unimaginable there's no computer
system CPU system that could even be
conceptualized that would have the
intricate behavior of the human brain
now of these 30,000 sets of genes strung
along the chromosomes over 75 percent of
the genes are expressed in the brain the
genome is like a symphony different
parts of the symphony play the different
instruments play at different times
during development there'll be sets of
genes that come on during heart
development and sets of genes that come
on brain development there's many
different forms of genes so the 75% of
genes actually could have many different
ice isoforms so for example one of the
genes I'll talk about a little bit later
the nerection gene has a thousand
different forms that adds even more
complexity this already complex system
and then finally the human being itself
is comprised of trillions of cells so an
average sized individual like myself
would be comprised of over 60 trillion
cells okay and as an individual and as a
society of course we are defined by the
infinite number of experiences and
exposures that we experience in our
lifetime and this is an affect our
environment and I'll come back to this
complexity at the very end of my talk
it's very hard to do experiments trying
to measure factors in the environment
because it's so complex much more
complex than the brain and the human
genome and we think of the human
individual I show the picture of Glenn
Glenn Gould because we're in the Glenn
Gould studio here at CBC I I'd like to
think of the the beautiful individuals
who can perform classical music or as
Joe pointed out the Wayne Gretzky's who
couldn't score 100 goals in a season and
I also think of my own children oil onto
the stage of their terrible twos where
you could never predict what they were
going to do and I've heard one parent
with a child with autism describe his
boy as being trapped in his terrible
twos 24 7 and multiply that by a hundred
and this is the type of behavioral
situation that we're dealing with in the
more severe forms of autism and as I
pointed out earlier i think it was quite
appropriate to put to put Glenn Gould
picture on this photograph because many
people thought that actually he was on
the autism spectrum he had very
particular habits about how he would sit
at his piano and play and what you would
eat before performances and I think
there's probably very good at evidence
that he has Asperger's syndrome so these
are the complexities that we'll talk
about we're trying to unravel the Enigma
that we are calling autism